so jetzt gibt es eine Änderung
ursprünglich ein anderer Punkt geplant
der wurde aber im Ausschuss festgehalten
seistum Top 14 wird jetzt aufgerufen
Notfallfonds für das Wissenschaftssystem
ein Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu und
Thomas der zombeck für die Union hatte
das Wort diese Krise ganz sicher sagen
ohne Forschung und ohne Wissenschaft
ohne Technologie werden wir uns aus der
mangelage nicht befreien können wir
brauchen also die Wissenschaft um uns zu
retten aber heute müssen wir darüber
reden die Wissenschaft zu retten wir
können hier im Deutschen Bundestag
locker 20 Prozent Energie sparen indem
wir die Heizung niedriger stellen indem
wir das Licht ausmachen aber wenn man
zum Beispiel eine bio-datenbank oder
eine Genbank betreibt wie das Unsere
Forschungsorganisation tun beim
Leibniz-Institut da werden Dinge
konserviert bei -196 grad wenn man
Tierhäuser betreibt wie das Max-Planck
Institut mit 50.000 Mäusen wenn man
einen Supercomputer wie das
Forschungszentrum Jülich sowie Standorte
auch in Garching und Stuttgart das
machen alleine der Supercomputer in
Jülich braucht 130 Gigawattstunden pro
Jahr wenn man einen
Teilchenbeschleuniger wie das Design
Hamburg hat 210 Gigawattstunden dann
wird glaube ich deutlich dass in der
Wissenschaft und Forschung nicht einfach
eben 20 Prozent gespart werden können
denn bei diesen ganzen Geräten über die
wir reden und über viele andere
Einrichtungen ist es eben so die kann
man nicht ein bisschen Herunterfahren
sondern hier reden wir über
Milliardeninvestitionen des Staates die
man am Ende einfach nur abschalten kann
und deshalb gibt es laute Hilferufe aus
der Wissenschaftsgemeinschaft Frau
Professor Becker von der Allianz der
Wissenschaftsorganisationen sieht ein
Bedarf von bis zu 3 Milliarden Euro
Professor Stratmann von transplank der
gerade ein Nobelpreis für Deutschland
noch mal nach Hause gebracht hat hat
diese Woche im Ausschuss von 100
Millionen Mehrkosten nur für Max-Planck
geredet in den nächsten Jahren bis zu
400 Millionen und was uns ganz besonders
nachdenklich macht und wovor wir Sorge
haben alleine bei Max Planck ich bleibe
dem Beispiel 1.000 neue Doktoranden pro
Jahr die eingestellt werden gerade ein
neues Nachwuchsprogramm mit 20 bis 30
Millionen alles Dinge die jetzt in Frage
gestellt werden müssen wahrscheinlich
wenn es keine Finanzierung in dieser
Notlage gibt meine Damen und Herren ist
droht der unwiederbringliche Verlust von
Forschungsergebnissen
und dann ist ja die Frage ist das
Problem eigentlich über Nacht gekommen
wir haben bereits am 28 Juli an die
benetz-ar geschrieben in persona Stefan
Albani und ich wir haben am 3 August
Frau Ministerin Ihnen eine kleine
Anfrage zu dem Thema geschrieben da
haben sie am 29.8 lapidaga geantwortet
es gibt in dieser Bundesregierung seit
Monaten Nachtstunden ein Rettungspaket
jagt das nächste drei entlastungspakete
Grundfreibetrag
Arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag Einmalzahlungen
für Empfänger Kinderbonus
energiepreispauschalen
Heizkostenzuschuss Homeoffice pauschale
Sparer-Pauschbetrag sogar einen
Spitzenausgleich für energieintensive
Unternehmen was ist bisher für Forschung
und Wissenschaft in diesem Paketen
erreicht worden
sie haben es schlicht vergessen es
werden seit Monaten Hilfspakete
geschnürt aber am Ende stehen viele
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
vor einem ganz schwierigen Szenario und
Frau Ministerin das was von ihnen
verlangt wird das was ihre Aufgabe es
ist Schutzpatronin der Forschung zu sein
und das erwarten viele da draußen und
die setzen ihre Hoffnungen in sie es ist
ein gutes Zeichen wenn aufgrund unserer
Debatte heute sie heute endlich jetzt im
Handelsblatt erklärt haben es braucht
auch einen Rettungsschirm für die
Wissenschaft aber Frau Ministerin das
alles am 20 Oktober ist viel zu spät und
viel zu ungewiss weil es eben noch kein
regierungskonvent ist
wir haben den Pakt für Forschung und
Innovation gemacht drei Prozent
Steigerung pro Jahr das ist der letzte
Rettungsanker den die
Wissenschaftsorganisationen gerade haben
sie Frau Ministerin haben uns
vorgehalten wir hätten damit den
Haushalt versteinert noch im Frühjahr
versteinert da frage ich mich natürlich
was waren ihre Ideen für den Haushalt
wenn Sie diese drei Prozent Wachstum als
Versteinerung gesehen haben ich will es
mir gar nicht vorstellen dati und
staatschancen ihre beiden
Lieblingsprogramme sind alle in weiter
Ferne und wer weiß ob sie nicht an
diesen Haushaltszahlen hätten kratzen
wollen um hier schneller das zu
realisieren und die Priorität muss darin
bestehen Sicherheit und Zuverlässigkeit
für das Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftssystem in Deutschland zu
geben
und wir haben das getan als wir vor zwei
Jahren in der schwierigen corona-phase
waren da wurden nicht nur
entlastungspakete gemacht sondern da
haben wir auch ein 15 Milliarden Paketen
nur für den Bereich BMWF gemacht alleine
die 9 Milliarden zum Wasserstoff mit
denen sie sich auch schmücken stammen
aus den corona-programmen zwei
Milliarden plus quantencomputing Mittel
für die künstliche Intelligenz und
vieles mehr und deshalb ist das was wir
jetzt brauchen und das haben wir hier
heute beantragt wir brauchen ein
Entlastungspaket für die Wissenschaft
darin muss drin sein geschützte Kunden
immer noch sind die
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen unsicher ob sie
in einer Mangellage nicht abgeschaltet
werden müssen sie müssen als geschützte
Kunden definiert werden wir brauchen zum
zweiten eine genaue Bedarfsanalyse
welche Einrichtungen haben welche
Energieverbräuche und können Sie selber
nicht einsparen und was muss ein solches
Paket leisten wir brauchen für einen
Notfallfonds einen
energiepreisdeckelwissenschaft und die
Zahl der Promotionsvorhaben darf nicht
sinken dafür braucht es eine Verabredung
mit den Ländern meine Damen und Herren
das ist heute die Chance für Sie als
Regierung endlich die Rolle einzunehmen
als Schutzpatron der Wissenschaft Frau
Ministerin tun Sie was es ist aller
aller höchste Zeit unsere Wissenschaft
ist in Gefahr es liegt in ihren Händen
jetzt endlich zu handeln
Thomas hier zumbek hat den Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion vorgestellt kurz
zusammengefasst es solle ein notfallfond
für die Wissenschaft her gemeinsam mit
den Ländern soll ein Entlastungspaket
für die Wissenschaft der Arbeit werden
und der nächste Redner kommt von der SPD
Holger Mann sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ob die Ionen und
elektronenquellen am leibnitz-institut
für oberflächenmodifizierung oder auch
die Kühlkammern oder dna-sequenzierer
mit Bioproben am Max-Planck-Institut für
evolutionäre Anthropologie und an der
Stelle sei gesagt ja jasonbeck weil sie
den Nobelpreis gerade jemand anders
zugesprochen haben das war schon 20
PayPal der die Forschung leistete die
ihm den Nobelpreis einbrachte und damit
sicherlich auch der Max-Planck-Institut
in dieser Stelle hier auch noch mal
Glückwunsch an ihn und die
Forschungsorganisation
ob im Gewächshaus des deutschen Zentrums
für integrative Biodiversitätsforschung
ob in leseseiter der deutschen Bücherei
oder auch in ihrem Archiv ja überall
brauchen Forscher und
Wissenschaftlerinnen Energie um ihre
Arbeit fortzusetzen oder auch nur um die
Forschungsgegenstände konservieren zu
können sowie an diesen vier
Forschungsinstitutionen im Nordosten von
Leipzig steigen gerade in ganz
Deutschland die Kosten für Strom und
Wärme kurzum natürlich auch die
Wissenschaft ist stark betroffen und
braucht Unterstützung in der
energiepreiskrise
und deshalb sage ich hier vorne deutlich
die SPD steht dafür dass
Forschungseinrichtung von der Gaspreis
und strompreisbremse profitieren
der für die Bundestagsfraktion hat genau
dies bereits am 2 september in ihrem
Positionspapier die Krise solidarisch
meistern beschlossen und nach den
folgenden koalitionsbeschlüssen ist die
Gaspreis und strompreisbremse nun in
Vorbereitung und das ist wirklich gut so
der Stelle sei auch schon mal gesagt
auch wenn uns das morgen noch mal
beschäftigen wird wir können alle morgen
im Bundestag mit dem Beschluss zum
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds selbst
einen Beitrag dazu leisten dass dies
schnell auf den Weg kommt
bin
zudem dankbar dass gerade erst am
Dienstag bei ackertech der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz eindeutig klar gemacht hat
natürlich fallen auch die
Forschungseinrichtungen unter die
Regelung der Gaspreis und zukünftigen
strompreisbremse
und wenn bisher schon galt Julian never
walk alone geht jetzt erst recht Juwel
never du research on you
die Wissenschaft ist also weder von der
Wirtschaft noch von der Gesellschaft
entkoppelt und kann sich daher darauf
verlassen dass wir gemeinsam solidarisch
die energiepreiskrise bewältigen die
Bundesregierung bereitet deshalb die
systemische Unterstützung per Gaspreis
und strompreisbremse vor und das halte
ich auch für richtig weil viele
Einzellösungen uns zu viel Zeit kosten
werden und dass der richtige Ansatz ist
und ich finde auch die Voraussetzung
dafür dass die schnell bei
Forschungseinrichtungen ankommt sind
gegeben die meisten Forschungsinstitute
haben eben einen großen
energiepreisanbieter mit langfristigem
Verträgen das Andocken an die Gaspreise
und strompreisbremse ist also im
Vergleich relativ einfach zu realisieren
wie eben auch bei großen
Industrieunternehmen zudem handelt es
sich hier nicht um gewinnen sondern um
gemeinwohlorientierte Einrichtung es
muss also auch niemand befürchten oder
gar unterstellen das subventionierte
Energie weiterverkauft wird an dieser
Stelle glaube ich ist dieses Instrument
geeignet um die Energiekosten abzufinden
darüber hinaus das haben sie ja gerade
auch noch mal gewürdigt haben sich eben
Bund und leidender im Pakt für
forschunginformationen langfristig zu
kontinuierlichen aufwüchsen der
Forschungsgemeinschaften verpflichtet
und da sei zumindest gesagt die vier
großen Forschungsgemeinschaften haben
aktuell mehrere hundert Millionen Euro
Rücklagen und wir können auch mal stolz
sagen sie haben auch das Know-how und
das Personal weitere Effizienzgewinne zu
heben
für die SPD kann ich zudem sagen wir
erwarten von der GWK am dritten November
weitere Einigungen zwischen Bund und
Ländern für die finanzielle
Unterstützung des gesamten
Wissenschaftssystems
ich halte daher bei allem Notwendigen
Problembewusstsein um Krisenbekämpfung
nichts von Panikmacher um
existenzbedrohungen wie in ihrem Antrag
formuliert geht es derzeit wirklich in
anderen Bereichen dennoch ich gebe Ihnen
eine Stelle recht das BMW F wird stärker
den Dialog mit den unterschiedlichen
Forschungseinrichtungen führen müssen
insbesondere was die Vorsorge für die
Risikovorsorge für den Fall einer
stromnotlage angeht
ich will zum Schluss zumindest noch kurz
darauf hinweisen dass wir neben all den
institutionellen Vorkehrungen auch auf
individuelle Ebene schon einiges getan
haben bereits mit mehreren
entlastungspaketen konkret mit dem
Heizkostenzuschuss 1 und ab heute auch
mit dem Heizkostenzuschuss 2 hoffe ich
doch das heißt mit der Einmalzahlung mit
dem BAföG-Erhöhung oder dem neuen
notfallmechanismus direkte finanzielle
Unterstützung gibt es eben darüber auch
für Lernende und forschende und ich will
hier festhalten wir werden im Verbund
mit den Ländern alles Notwendige tun den
Betrieb für die Bildungs- und
Forschungseinrichtungen zu sichern und
damit Zukunft für unser Land und die
Wissenschaft danke schön
Deutschlands energieintensivstes
Forschungszentrum ist das Desi deutsche
Elektronen
synchronen in Hamburg so heißt es 152 GB
Stunden verbraucht es dieses Jahr wenn
es nur 20% weniger bezahlen kann im
nächsten Jahr das würde bedeuten ein
ganzer Monat weniger Messzeit für
Vorstellungen Forscher jährlich nutzen
3000 Wissenschaftler die Anlage 250 von
ihnen käme mich zum Zug so sind die
realen Probleme in Einzelprojekten Mark
jungen jetzt von der AFD gesprochen und
zwar von politischen Illusionen und
Ideologien mit der Realität die
Illusionen sind überaus hartnäckig wie
wir bis stürzt feststellen müssen aber
das Realitätsprinzip ist härter und es
wird eine nach der anderen zum platzen
bringen es ist nur noch eine Frage der
kurzen Zeit meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland ist mittlerweile so
heruntergewirtschaftet von den
wechselnden Illusionisten auf der
Regierungsbank dass wir allen Ernstes
darüber diskutieren welche
Wirtschaftszweige welche
Bevölkerungsgruppen oder jetzt welche
Forschungsstätten demnächst noch Strom
und Heizung haben und wo beides
abgeschaltet werden muss ich frage Sie
alle merken Sie eigentlich noch in
welchen Abgrund Sie dieses Land hinein
manövrieren von einer führenden
Industrienation zum Industriemuseum wenn
es so weitergeht meine Damen und Herren
heute fordert die CDU von der Ampel ein
Entlastungspaket und ein notfallfond für
die Wissenschaft die in der Tat in den
Energiekosten zu ersticken droht am
Forschungszentrum Jülich rechnet man
dieses Jahr mit Mehrkosten von 40
Prozent 2023 könnten sich die
Energiekosten verdoppeln dann wird am
Personal gespart werden müssen vor allem
junge Wissenschaftler werden ihre
Stellen verlieren ein großer Blackout
hätte existenzbedrohende Folgen für die
Forschung allein schon wegen der
ausfallenden Datensicherung aber der
Brandstifter ruft doch hier nach der
feuerwehrwerte CDU denn sie sind ja
selbst maßgeblich verantwortlich für
diese m es war die schwarz-gelbe
Koalition und der Kanzlerin Merkel die
2011 den Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
beschlossen hat und es war Merkel die
Deutschland hochgradig abhängig von
russischem Gas gemacht hat zusammen mit
der SPD haben Sie dann den Grünen
windradwahn ins Werk gesetzt der ein
energiepolitisches Lustschloss war und
ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes weil
die Windkraft eben nicht grundlastfähig
ist und sie fordern ja auch jetzt nur
mit großem Tamtam die
Laufzeitverlängerung aber halten
prinzipiell am Ausstieg aus der
Kernkraft fest das ist doch armselig und
ideenlos jetzt stellen sie plötzlich die
Kurzatmigkeit der aktuellen Bekämpfung
der Energiekrise fest und fordern eine
langfristige Strategie für sichere und
bezahlbare Energieversorgung ohne eine
einzige Idee in ihrem Antrag auch nur
anzudeuten worin diese Strategie
bestehen könnte das muss man erstmal
fertig bringen dabei liegt es auf der
Hand dass es nur nur um die Rückkehr zur
Kernenergie und die Beendigung der
Russland Sanktionen gehen kann meine
Damen und Herren hören Sie auch bitte
auf mit der abgeschmackten Ausrede Putin
und der Krieg sein an allen Schuld nein
deutsche Zahlen mit die höchsten
Strompreise weltweit beim Gas doppelt so
viel wie unsere polnischen Nachbarn und
etwa dreimal so viel wie in Ungarn nicht
wegen des kriegesinn der Ukraine der hat
die hausgemachten Probleme nur
verschärft sondern wegen der dümmsten
Energiepolitik der Welt wie das Wort
Journal treffen schrieb nämlich der
deutschen und es rächt sich jetzt bitter
dass man in Deutschland die
ingenieurskompetenz in Sachen Kernkraft
systematisch zerstört hat auf Betreiben
der Grünen Ideologen hier und das auch
der politische Druck auf die
Wissenschaft kaum noch eine
wissenschaftliche offen öffentliche
offene Diskussion über die Ursachen des
Klimawandels und den Umgang damit
zulässt wir müssen wegkommen von
Weltrettung von Deutschland aus und
stattdessen hören Sie doch mal besser zu
kreative Ideen entwickeln wie wir uns an
höhere Temperaturen und wechselnde
Wetterlagen anpassen können ohne unsere
Wirtschaft und aktuell sogar unser
Wissenschaftssystem massiv zu schädigen
da können auch große Chancen daraus
erwachsen die afd-fraktion ich komme zum
Schluss ist für die prioritäre
Stromversorgung wichtiger
Forschungseinrichtungen im akuten
Krisenfall aber wir sehen darin nur eine
hilflose krisenbekämpfer
Symptombekämpfung wir brauchen die
energiepolitische Wende jetzt bevor es
zur Katastrophe kommt vielen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über einen
Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion Notfallfonds
für das Wissenschaftssystem
nächste Rednerin Laura Kraft für die
bündnisgründen sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich denke wir alle sind uns in
einer Sache einig Wissenschaft und
Innovation gehen Hand in Hand und die
wissen ohne Wissenschaft gäbe ist kein
Fortschritt und wir müssen jetzt auch
die Hochschulen und auch die
Forschungseinrichtungen in unserem Land
schützen Wissenschaft ist der Schlüssel
für die Überwindung von Krise und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt hier mehr tun
in
in dieser aktuellen Krise ist das
Wissenschaftssystem von enormen
Energiepreisen betroffen und muss auch
über den Winter kommen und darum müssen
wir Forschungseinrichtungen universitäre
wie auch außeruniversitäre während der
Krise unterstützen und gerade deshalb
hat das BMBF bereits beim Bundeskanzler
für geworben dass Wissenschaft auch aber
auch
energieintensive Forschungseinrichtung
im wirtschaftlichen abwehrshare
geschirrabwehrschirm Entschuldigung der
Bundesregierung berücksichtigt werden es
ist der klärteste der Ampel das
Wissenschaftssystem unbedingt zu
schützen und ich bin froh dass wir heute
über die Bedeutung der Energieversorgung
der Forschungseinrichtungen diskutieren
der Antrag der Union enthält
Schlussfolgerungen die so nicht ganz
richtig sind und wir wollen auf keinen
Fall dass es zu irgendwelchen Schäden
kommt wie etwa an unwiederbringlichen
biodatenbanken oder das Tiere in
Tierhäusern zu Schaden kommen oder dass
irgendwelche Daten verloren gehen das
wollen wir natürlich nicht und da werden
wir auch alles für tun dass das nicht
passiert wir nehmen die kritische Lage
äußerst ernst und wir arbeiten mit
hochdruckanlösungen
Entlastung mit besonderem Fokus auf
Bildung und Wissenschaft die müssen
jetzt folgen und das werden sie auch es
darf jedoch nicht sein dass Hochschulen
wieder befürchten müssen ausschließlich
in den Online-Betrieb zurückzukehren und
die Kosten die dann wohl möglich bei den
Hochschulen eingespart werden die landen
ja dann wieder bei den Studierenden und
die haben in der Pandemie ja nun
wirklich am meisten zurückgesteckt
die Situation der Kostensteigerung muss
im Gesamtpaket betrachtet werden
Unterstützung muss auch bei den
Hochschulen den Mensen und den
studierendenwerken ankommen dabei hoffe
ich auf gute Zusammenarbeit mit den
Ländern die hierbei auch gefragt sind
Unterstützung der Studierenden ist im
Bereich Verpflegungen und Wohnen von
immenser Bedeutung denn das sind mit die
größten Kostenpunkte die Studierende
haben die Mieten in Wohnheim steigen
teilweise deutlich mein Wahlkreise einen
der Uni Siegen werden ab Januar zum
Beispiel die Wohnheim mieten um 70 bis
100 Euro pro Monat angehoben
gleichzeitig wird aber oftmals auch das
Essen in den Mensen teurer das kann man
natürlich auch verstehen weil die wenn
Sie natürlich auch mehr Kosten haben
durch die lebensmittelpreissteigerung
und damit Studierende sich nicht
entscheiden müssen zwischen warmer
Wohnung oder warmer Mahlzeit dann muss
nach der strompreisbremse dann auch die
mensa-preisbremse kommen
die Frage wo gespart wird wo nicht die
ist eben in dieser Zeit von großer
Bedeutung und teilweise besteht ein sehr
gutes Einsparpotenzial und darum freut
mich die Nachricht dass viele
Hochschulen das Ziel verfolgen 15 bis 20
Prozent an Energieeinsparen zu wollen
das ist aber an anderen Stellen
schwierig und wenn Einrichtungen ihre
Forschung nicht weiter betreiben können
dann handeln wir uns Probleme mit
langfristigen Konsequenzen ein denn
Forschung ist eben ein großer
Innovationstreiber in Deutschland und
die gesellschaftlichen und die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen bei Einschnitten
in der Wissenschaft die während
verheerend Wissenschaft braucht
Finanzierung Sicherheit Stabilität und
dafür stehen wir ein dafür setzen wir
uns ein vielen Dank
für die Fraktion Petra Sitte hat jetzt
das Wort für die winke sie Sprecherin
für Forschung Technologie und
Innovationspolitik für ihre Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ja
für Wissenschaft und Forschung ist die
Lage gerade wirklich ernst viele in der
Wissenschaft Einrichtungen genauso wie
forschende und Studierende sind mit
explodierenden verpreisen ohne Frage
überfordert da stimme ich den Kollegen
zu Energiekrise und Inflationen Folgen
nunmehr auf fast oder gut zwei Jahre
Pandemie und in dieser Zeit sind schon
Forschungsprojekte weggerutscht Lehrende
und Lernende haben sich aufgeräumt um
wissenschafts- und Lehrbetrieb zu
sichern und ich kann da nur sagen DANKE
DANKE
Studierenden sind in dieser Zeit
Nebenjobs verloren gegangen ohne das
wirklich geholfen wurde also
Tatenlosigkeit in der Krise kennt man
nicht erst von dieser Regierung so weit
so schlecht was ist zu bedenken was ist
zu tun erstens ich will das breiter
aufstellen als dass der Kollege von der
CDU gemacht hat Hochschulen brauchen
dringend Unterstützung damit der lehr-
und Forschungsbetrieb ohne Einschränkung
weitergehen kann und das haben sie auch
versprochen Hochschulen sind aber eben
auch seit Jahren unterfinanziert und das
belastet längst Studierende und
beschäftigte noch ein Winter mit
eingeschränkter Präsenz diesmal aber
weil es zu kalt ist müssen wir unbedingt
verhindern
zweitens
ich will nicht irgendeine Mensa bremse
ich rede über das Deutsche Studentenwerk
deutsche Studierendenwerk die wir nicht
auf den Energiekosten sitzen lassen
können klar wie sollen denn Menschen
sonst offen gehalten werden aber
umgekehrt wie sollen den beispielsweise
auch Studierendenwohnheime erschwinglich
betrieben werden und eben dann auch
vermietet werden können und dort erleben
wir bereits jetzt Mietsteigerungen von
60 Euro sie können ja selber mal rechnen
wie weit man beispielsweise dabei auf
den Heizkostenzuschuss zugreifen kann
der ja eigentlich noch nicht mal
originär für die Miete gedacht ist also
es muss mehr passieren da stimme ich nun
wiederum der Kollegin zu drittens das
ist noch nicht erwähnt worden aber da
haben wir der brennt wirklich der Baum
viele
universitätskliniker können derzeit
nicht sagen wie sie ihren Betrieb
weiterführen sollen wenn Energiepreise
tatsächlich um bis zu 400% steigen auch
Sachmittel Lebensmittel medizinischer
Bedarf sind um gut 30% gestiegen auch
heute dürfen wir nicht allein lassen es
sind ja auch
ausbildungskrankenhäuser bzw
Maximalversorger viertens
Unikliniken wie Hochschulen fällt jetzt
der
Sanierungsstau doppelt auf die Füße
allein durch unikliniker in meinem
Bundesland Sachsen-Anhalt haben ein
Sanierungsbedarf von 1,5 Milliarden
bundesweit sind es aber 35 bis 60
Milliarden Sanierungsstau klar in also
Energie Ineffizienz wird das Thema
bleiben gerade eben bei Gebäuden und
deshalb meine Damen und Herren machen
Sie endlich den Hochschulbau wieder zu
einer Gemeinschaftsaufgabe von Bund und
Ländern das war damals ein Fehler es
abzuschaffen
fünftens und letztens
sie haben es richtig gesagt Hochschulen
sollen als geschützte Einrichtung gelten
das ist die richtige Entscheidung das
ist seit 1.9 diesen Jahres geklärt geben
sie aber auch den studierendenwerken
diesen Schutzstatus und für beide meine
Damen und Herren muss zwingend die
gaspreisbremse gelten klar Herr
jazzombeck selbstverständlich muss die
Klärung auch herbeigelführt werden für
außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen da stimme ich
Ihnen völlig zu aber schließlich muss
auch der Zukunftsvertrag Studium und
Lehre den steigenden Preisen angepasst
werden die Hilfen sind natürlich nicht
kostenneutral wer das glaubt erzählt
hier Mord und misst das ist alles Unsinn
natürlich müssen wir da dran natürlich
müssen wir mit den Ländern verhandeln ob
das für den Pakt für Forschung und
Innovation auch notwendig ist wird sich
erweisen bei den Gesprächen mit den
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen also wir sollten
uns nichts vormachen wir sollten ehrlich
sein und wir sollten in dieser
Verhandlung eintreten um dann eben auch
den Hochschulen den studierendenwerken
den unikliniker und den
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen unter die Arme
zu greifen danke für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
für die FDP-Fraktion spricht Professor
Dr Stefan Seiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute über den Antrag der CDU zum Thema
Entlastungspaket und Notfall vor
einrichten um Schaden vom deutschen
Wissenschaftssystem abzuwenden das ist
ein aktueller und relevanter Antrag und
es geht in der Tat um unser
Wissenschaftssystem das international
eine Spitzenstellung einnimmt und wir
haben es jetzt schon dann verschiedene
Stelle gehört das Wissenschaftssystem
alle Beteiligten dieses Systems haben in
den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren zwei
dreivierteljahren sind es mittlerweile
große Leistungen gebracht und dafür
sollten wir alle gemeinsam dankbar sein
und verteile ich ihre Einschätzung liebe
Kolleginnen
dass wir da nicht genug danken können es
waren extrem schwierige Bedingungen und
die Bedingungen dürfen jetzt nicht
schwieriger werden das ist auf jeden
Fall klar
Aktualität und Relevanz sind aber
letztendlich nicht zwingend das was eine
zielorientierte und lösungsorientierte
Vorgehensweise begründet vielmehr müssen
wir uns Gedanken noch mal drüber machen
was sind die Ursachen und ich denke wir
sind uns ja alle einig im Haus wie so
vielleicht eine kleine Gruppe zu meiner
Rechten dass der Ursache der putinsche
Angriffskrieg ist damit müssen wir klar
anerkennen die Ursache liegt dort und
der zweite Sache die wir anerkennen
müssen ist natürlich dass wir in der
Vergangenheit eine Energiepolitik
gemacht haben die zu stark auf die
Abhängigkeit einzelner großen
Lieferanten gesetzt hat das sind aber
Dinge die werden wir kurzfristig so
nicht lösen können sondern kurzfristig
drückt die außenuniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen die
Universitäten die Hochschulen das
Problem gestiegener Energiepreise
gestiegener weiterer Kosten wir haben
noch das Thema Information wir haben
auch das Thema das natürlich Inflation
durchaus auch zu Lohnforderungen führen
wird im Tarifbereich die Hochschulen die
Universitäten die
Forschungseinrichtungen stehen vor
diesem problemiversitäten die
diesem Problem ist darüber im Klaren
werden wie wir dieses Thema angehen
niemand wird in diesem Haus bereit sein
das Wissenschaftssystem so zu gefährden
dass wichtige Daten wichtige Zellproben
wichtige burkanne verloren gehen und wir
sind uns alle darüber einig dass wir in
diesem Fall aktiv werden müssen und das
ist das was mich jetzt zum Beispiel am
Antrag der CDU etwas stört nämlich es
wird von einer Tatenlosigkeit gesprochen
diese Tatenlosigkeit ist nicht gegeben
die Ministerin setzt sich für das
Wissenschaftssystem ein wir haben das
Faktum heute da zum Beispiel nachlesbar
im Handelsblatt dass die Ministerin
fordert dass die außeruniversitären
Einrichtungen in den Abwehrschirm oder
hinter den Abwehrschirm genommen werden
die außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen haben große
Rücklagen sie sind bereit diese
Rücklagen abzubauen das ist das
solidarische Beitrag dieser
Institutionen
aber sie werden und das ist unsere auch
unsere unterstützen wir sehr in diesen
Abwehrschirm übernommen werden müssen
die Schule und Hochschulen sind
auch als geschützte Kunden auf der Liste
sie werden das werden darüber haben so
wir wissen die Ministerin für Forschung
und Bildung und der Wirtschaftsminister
sich ausgetauscht und es gibt wohl auch
dort in die Richtung dass es gut wird
und das weichste was natürlich die Sache
ist die Hochschulen bereiten
Notfallpläne vor sie nehmen
Sparmaßnahmen das ist der Beitrag der
Hochschulen es darf aber nicht passieren
dass die Hochschulen dann wieder aus dem
präsenzbetrieb herausgehen weil das
wollen wir sicher hier in diesem Haus
alle gemeinsam nicht aber wir wissen
auch das Spielraum für die Hochschulen
ist begrenzt es gibt ein Sparpotenzial
aber dieses Sparpotenzial ist endlich
das wurde auch schon an verschiedener
Stelle angesprochen und da kommt jetzt
der nächste Spieler letztendlich auf den
Platz und dieser nächste Spieler das
sind die Länder
und Daten ist schon die Frage erlaubt
was haben die Länder bisher getan um
deren Hochschulen zu helfen einzelne
Länder haben schon Einstellungen gemacht
in den Haushalt andere Länder sind noch
im such- und Findungsprozess und es gibt
auch Länder ich schaue ich sie wissen
ich komme aus Baden-Württemberg ich
schaue in Richtung mein östlichen
Nachbar die haben bisher gar nichts
gemacht und warten auf den Bund bzw
schieben es auf den Bund da so können
wir diese Krise nicht angehen und lösen
und so lassen wir letztendlich unser
Hochschulsystem allein die Länder haben
einen Haushalt tierischen Spielraum sie
sind Träger der Hochschule und sie
dürfen sich nicht immer nur mit den
Leistungen in tollen Ergebnissen der
Hochschulen schmücken und wenn sie Not
geraten dann trägt man nach jemand
anderem dann ruft man nach der großen
Schwester oder der Schutzpatronin wie
das Kollege ja zumbek vorher gesagt hat
meine Hand die Ministerin ist im
Austausch mit den Stakeholdern ansonsten
hätte es diese Maßnahmen diese
Aktivitäten letztendlich nicht gegeben
die Koalition bekennt sich zum Schutz
des Wissenschaftssystem wir haben viele
Maßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht
dankenswerterweise hat Kollege zumbeck
die alle aufgeführt so dass ich es hier
an dieser Stelle nicht mehr tun muss und
wir seien Sie versichert gemeinsam
werden wir das meistern wir werden aber
die Solidarität aller Beteiligten
brauchen um diesen Weg zu gehen um das
Bildungssystem zu sichern denn und damit
komme ich zum Schluss unser
Wissenschaftssystem ist Garant dafür
dass wir technologische Souveränität
wieder erreichen können dass wir im
systemwettbewerb der sich international
ergeben hat auch wieder eine starke
Position einnehmen müsste und das müsste
Grund für uns alle gemeinsam sein
gemeinsam ohne Polemik in diesem Feld
nach vorne zu gehen vielen Dank
Stefan Seite war das für die FDP der
Bundestag der debattiert über ein Antrag
der cdu/csu-fraktion Notfallfonds für
das Wissenschaftssystem und die
zuständige stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Union Nadine
schön erhält jetzt das Wort sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen das Problem über das wir heute
diskutieren das fällt ja wahrlich nicht
vom Himmel seit Monaten diskutieren wir
in Deutschland darüber wie wir mit
dieser Energiekrise umgehen und was uns
alle frustriert ist dass diese
Bundesregierung nach wie vor kein
Gesamtkonzept vorliegt wie sie die
exorbitanten Energiekosten Steigerungen
bewältigt und wie sie auch auf der
Angebotsseite dafür sorgt dass wir mehr
Energie in unser Land bekommen auch
heute nicht
und was uns besonders schmerzt ist dass
die Auswirkungen auf Wissenschaft und
Forschung enorm sind und das hat diese
Debatte deutlich gezeigt wir haben bei
den Forschungs- und den
wissenschaftssituation Einrichtungen die
Situation dass sie mit Blackouts
schlicht nicht leben können es wird IRA
parabler Schaden entstehen wenn die
Energieversorgung bei gewissen
Instituten ganz ausfällt und auch die
enormen Energiekosten Steigerung
teilweise wird um das wird über das
zweieinhalbfach gesprochen können die
Einrichtungen nicht alleine schultern
die Erkenntnis ist da zumindest bei uns
schon lange und deshalb sind wir sehr
früh tätig geworden wir haben im Juli
bereits den Präsident der
Bundesnetzagentur angeschrieben und
haben gefragt wie sieht es denn aus mit
den Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen sind die denn
gedeckt von diesem Schutzschirm und die
Antwort war der Kollege gerdin sagt
die Antwort war nein
Hochschulen ich kann sogar zitieren aus
der Antwort von 29 auch aus der Antwort
vom Juli
Schulen und Hochschulen gehören zu den
geschützten Kunden nicht aber
Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen wir haben
daraufhin die Bundesregierung
angeschrieben und haben gefragt ob sie
denn mal mit der Bundesnetzagentur in
den Austausch gehen und ob sie sich
nicht dafür einsetzen wollen dass die
Energiesicherheit gewährleistet ist bei
den Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen und die
Antwort
führt die Bundesregierung hat die
Versorgungssicherheit der Forschung eine
hohe Bedeutung und ein
Versorgungsengpass in diesem Bereich
hätte weitreichende Folgen das BMBF ist
hierzu im Austausch mit dem
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz der Bundesnetzagentur sowie
mit den wissenschaftsakteuren ein
Austausch am 29 August 2022 wir haben
aber jetzt Mitte Oktober und jetzt
können Sie hier ganz entspannt sagen das
sind doch erst zwei Monate uns läuft die
Zeit davon jeder einzelne Tag ist
wichtig um eine Lösung zu finden und wir
haben in diesen zwei Monaten keine
einzige Lösung berührt keine einzige und
heute heute das ist die Lösung heute
kündigt die Bundesministerin im
Handelsplatz an dass es sich für einen
Rettungsschirm für
spitzenforschungseinrichtungen einsetzt
heute wo unser Antrag hier im debattiert
wird das ist ja erstmal schön wir hätten
uns über ein paar mehr Details zu diesem
Antrag gefreut die Ministerin kann nicht
sprechen sie muss jetzt heute in den
Haushaltsausschuss aber es hätte doch
andere Wege gegeben als eine Kachel bei
Twitter des BMBF ich hätte mich auch für
die Einrichtungen gefreut wenn wir mehr
Details über diesen Rettungsschirm heute
erfahren hätten
und jetzt wünschen wir der Ministerin
natürlich viel Glück bei ihren
Verhandlungen im Haushaltsausschuss
vielleicht geht es auch genau um diese
Themen toi toi toi
aber die Dynamik dieser Debatte lässt
mich nicht glauben dass die Koalition in
Gänze sich dafür einst ist einsetzt das
hier sehr schnell was passiert Frau
Kraft sagt zwar wir arbeiten mit
Hochdruck anlösungen und anderen sagen
auch dass der Bedarf da ist aber Fakt
ist dass der Winter jetzt ist und die
gaspreisbremse greift im Frühjahr und
fährt die Einrichtungen ist für den
Winter keine Vorsorge getroffen nicht
bei Blackouts nicht bei exorbitant
steigenden Kosten wir erwarten heute
Lösungen heute hätten sie die Chance
gehabt im Deutschen im Plenum dieses
Deutschen Bundestages diese zu
präsentieren sie haben es nicht getan
deshalb haben wir
Ihnen heute diesen Antrag vorgelegt wir
fordern ganz konkret und Sie können sich
einfach an unserem Antrag orientieren
wir fordern dass die
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen von der
Bundesnetzagentur als geschützte Kunden
eingestuft werden
wir fordern ganz konkret einen
Entlastungspaket für die Wissenschaft um
den drohenden Schaden für uns zu
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen abzuwenden
wir fordern ganz konkret eine
Notfallfonds
werden muss
dann muss das irgendwo wenn wenn Energie
bezahlt werden muss dann muss ein
anderer Stelle gespart werden und das
hat enorme Folgen für das Gesamtsystem
Wissenschaft und Forschung darunter
Leitern die Doktoranden darunter leiten
die das Wissenschaftssystem insgesamt
und das müssen wir verhindern da waren
wir uns ja auch heute einig und wir
fordern dass die Bundesregierung
schnellstmöglich zu einem Energiegipfel
für die Wissenschaft einlädt damit all
diese Themen zügig in trockene Tücher
gepackt werden können folgen Sie uns am
Antrag stimmen Sie mit unserem Antrag
wir haben konkrete Vorschläge gemacht
nicht das heute sondern seit Juli und es
ist ein leichtes dem zu folgen wir
erweitern nicht nur schöne Tweets und
nicht nur schöne Reden im Deutschen
Bundestag sondern ganz konkrete Taten
Nadine schön und die Union fordert in
diesem Antrag unter anderem ja einen
Notfallfonds für die Wissenschaft und
Nadine schön hat es angesprochen heute
meldet das Handelsblatt dass Ministerin
Bettina stark Watzinger die
Bundesforschungsministerin einen
Rettungsschirm für
spitzenforschungseinrichtungen fordert
für die SPD jetzt Oliver Kaczmarek wir
müssen einordnen was muss man
grundsätzlich tun in dieser
energiepreiskrise was muss nur ein
spezifisch für die Wissenschaft tun und
was heißt das eigentlich für
langfristige Perspektiven der
Wissenschaft und Frau schön ich muss
sagen ich habe etwas anderen Eindruck
was die Schnelligkeit im Handeln angeht
weil bei der grundsätzlichen Bearbeitung
der Frage wie wir mit der Krise umgehen
geht es darum vier Punkte und die
Versorgungslage die gesichert werden
muss es geht um Preise die gebremst
werden müssen es geht darum zu helfen
mit Entlastungen und es geht darum
Energie einzusparen und muss man mal
ganz ehrlich sagen
während ihre Fraktion hier noch so
Sachen wie gasmoratorien gefordert hat
ist die Bundesregierung losgegangen und
hat dafür gesorgt dass wir lng-terminals
bauen das Speicher geführt werden dass
die neue lieferantengas liefern und
damit dafür gesorgt dass überhaupt
Forschung betrieben werden kann im
nächsten Winter während ihre Fraktion
dann noch im Tiefschlaf gelegen hat also
da bin ich nicht ihrer Meinung
vor dem Hintergrund dieser vier
Herausforderungen die wir allgemein und
für alle und damit auch für Wissenschaft
und Forschung zu lösen haben müssen wir
natürlich über die spezifischen Bedarfe
von Wissenschaft und Forschung sprechen
was sind die genauen Bedarfe was sind
basisbedarfe beim Energieverbrauch
welche zusätzlichen Bedarfe müssen
abgedeckt werden und wo kann überhaupt
Energie gespart werden die Hochschulen
haben sich auf den Weg gemacht aber wir
wissen es gibt Forschungseinrichtungen
nicht nur tiersammlungen sondern auch
andere wo überhaupt keine Energie
eingespart werden kann weil die Anlagen
durchlaufen müssen und deswegen müssen
wir darauf aufbauend im Dialog mit den
außeruniversitären
Forschungsorganisation mit den
Hochschulen auch passgenaue Lösungen
finden für die Wissenschaft und ich bin
der Meinung die Expertenkommission Gas
wir haben hat da schon Ideen auch
geliefert mit denen wir uns auch
auseinandersetzen können und wo wir auch
um eine schnelle Umsetzung bemüht sind
es geht darum zu überprüfen wie wir den
fuel Switch also den Umstieg auf andere
Energieträger finanziell unterstützen
können wie wir härtefallfonds
möglicherweise brauchen nur ich will
eins sagen das ist nicht eine
Herausforderung an die Bundesregierung
sondern es geht an mehrere Akteure und
ich habe gestern im Ausschuss gehört
dass der Präsident der
Max-Planck-Gesellschaft gesagt hat dass
er sich diese Herausforderung sehr wohl
bewusst ist dass die
Forschungsorganisation ein Beitrag
leisten müssen und ich habe einen
kleinen Tipp sie sind ja auch an einigen
Landesregierung beteiligt heute findet
die Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz statt
vielleicht haben Sie ja in ihren Ländern
wo sie auch in der Regierung sind den
Hinweis auch gegeben darauf dass wir
Forschungseinrichtungen in besonderer
Weise schützen müssen wenn das gelingt
dann bin ich mir sicher wenn wir auch
eine gute Lösung gemeinsam mit den
Ländern finden und mit den
Forschungseinrichtungen
und mein Kollege Holger man hat gerade
schon gesagt der Bundeskanzler selbst
hat in dieser Woche bei der
Festveranstaltung der ackertech deutlich
gemacht dass die Bundesregierung dieses
Problem nicht nur sieht sondern dass sie
an konkreten Lösungen arbeitet im Dialog
mit dem Forschungsorganisation mit den
Ländern und die
Wissenschaftsorganisationen in diesem
Land wissen dass solch eine Rede nicht
daher gesprochen ist sondern dass sie
sich auf das Wort des Kanzlers verlassen
können und wir als Regierungskoalition
werden das auch unterstützen
die wichtige Frage die viele umtreibt in
den Forschungsorganisationen ist eine
die längerfristig darüber hinausgeht
natürlich müssen wir die Energiekrise
überwinden aber jeder weiß doch 100
Milliarden für die Bundeswehr 100
Milliarden für entlastungspakete 200
Milliarden für den wirtschaftlichen
plus die Belastungen die wir im
Bundeshaushalt haben aus der
corona-pandemie die sind ja nicht weg
das eng die Spielräume für öffentliche
Haushalte ein und viele
Wissenschaftsorganisationen fragen sich
wie geht es eigentlich in dieser lang in
dieser Lage langfristig weiter und ich
will an dieser Stelle sagen dass in den
Fakten und nicht in den Reden der
Oppositionsfraktion ziemlich deutlich
abzulesen ist dass die Priorität für
Bildung und Forschung in dieser
Regierungskoalition in dieser
Bundesregierung erhalten bleibt das
zeigt der Haushalt den wir demnächst
abschließen werden für das nächste Jahr
und das zeigt auch der Pakt für
Forschung und Innovation und ich muss da
schon sagen hey jetzt haben Beck und
Frau schön ich war schon sehr irritiert
dass ich heute gelesen habe dass sie der
Bundesregierung unterstellen die
Aufwüchse würden den Fragen ich meine
das ist im bmbf-haushalt wenig
disponible Mittel gibt das ist eine
Tatsachenfeststellung die viele
Vorgängerinnen von Frau starkwatzinger
auch so getroffen haben auch aus ihrer
Fraktion dass sie daraus aber ableiten
der Aufwuchs der vereinbart worden ist
in der Bund ländervereinbarung von drei
Prozent in jedem Jahr für die
paktorganisation würde damit in Frage
stellen ist eine wirklich absurde
Verdrehung von Tatsachen die hätte ich
Ihnen wirklich nicht zugetraut das muss
man mal ganz ehrlich sagen
ich hätte gedacht sie wissen dass man
eine bundländervereinbarung nicht
einseitig kürzen kann kündigen kann wir
werden in der GWK in dieser in der
nächsten Woche in der übernächsten Woche
glaube ich Entscheidungen haben womit
auch die Wissenschaftsorganisationen bzw
die Hochschulen langfristige
planungsperspektiven erhalten werden und
insofern ist völlig klar und auch gegen
jede Rede der Opposition klar und
nachvollziehbar die Priorität für
Bildung und forschen bleibt und wir
haben eine Regierungskoalition die sich
in diesen schwierigen Zeiten für unsere
Haushalte für die Gesellschaft aber doch
klar und mit viel Geld und Fakten hinter
unsere Forschungsorganisation Stellen
herzlichen Dank
gesagt Oliver Kaczmarek von der SPD die
Kultusminister der Länder übrigens die
stellen sich auch hinter die
Forschungsinstitutionen und die
Forschungseinrichtungen denn die haben
Anfang Oktober bereits eine Forderung
abgegeben dass die Sicherstellung des
präsenzbetriebs an Hochschulen und
Forschungseinrichtungen und
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen auch im Falle
einer gasmangelage gewährleistet werden
sollen
mit diesem Antrag auch deren schaden
denn sie selbst in der Regierung mit
angerichtet hat doch er geht in die
richtige Richtung und benannt treffen
die Problemfelder deshalb sonnweg vielen
Dank für den Antrag unsere
Forschungseinrichtungen müssen bei den
ausufernden Energiekosten deutlich
entlastet werden das betrifft
energieintensive
großforschungsvorhaben wie denn
kernfusionsversuchsreaktor Wendelstein
7x oder den teilchenbeschleiß im Neckar
doch auch weniger spektakuläre Anlagen
wie Reinräume
langzeitexperimente in der chemischen
biologischen Forschungen in der
Materialforschung und viele andere
Forschungsvorhaben sind gefährdet
Beispiele wurden heute viele genannt
Monate dauernde Experimente sind umsonst
wenn die Energieversorgung nicht
gewährleistet ist
Forschung braucht Energie zu bezahlbaren
Preisen sonst gehen dort die Lichter aus
mit verheerenden Folgen für die Zukunft
Deutschlands
dies wurde von der Bundesregierung
bisher nicht berücksichtigt warum Werte
Regierungsfraktionen muss solch ein
Antrag erst aus der Opposition kommen
wieso kommen Sie darauf nicht selbst
doch mit einem energiepreisdeckel für
die Forschung ist es nicht getan
Inflation und Energiepreise sind zu
einer schweren Belastung für die
Wissenschaft geworden besserung ist
nicht in Sicht darum muss ich leider
wieder an den unhaltbaren Zustand
erinnern dass das Gesamtbudget des BMBF
für 2023 gegenüber dem laufenden Jahr
quasi stagniert und nicht einmal
ansatzweise die Inflation ausgleicht
selbst wenn morgen der Krieg in der
Ukraine beendet sein sollte wird die
energieversorgungslage keinen Deut
besser sein wie geht es dann weiter
darauf gibt auch der vorliegende Antrag
keine Antwort Forschung und Wissenschaft
sind die Grundlage unseres Wohlstands
und ein Versprechen an die Zukunft sie
müssen in der materiellen Ausstattung
endlich den Stellenwert bekommen der
ihnen zusteht
es ist darüber hinaus festzuhalten dass
die gegenwärtige Krise auch Ausfluss
einer politisch gewollten einseitigen
Ausrichtung der Forschung selbst ist
weil die Forschung an der friedlichen
Nutzung der Kernenergie und
synthetischen Kraftstoffen an neuen
umweltverträglichen Technologien für
Kohle und Gaskraftwerke im
ideologiegebäude dieser aber auch der
Vorgängerregierung keinen Platz hatte
kann Deutschland seine Energiebedarf
nicht aus eigener Kraft decken
ich fordere insbesondere Sie werte
Kollegen von der FDP auf sich wenigstens
in diesem Fall gemeinsam mit der
Opposition für eine Politik der Vernunft
und des Fortschritts einzusetzen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Herr geringer hat jetzt das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Vorsitzende des Ausschusses für Bildung
Forschung und Technologie
vollgeabschätzung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe Union zu historischen
Einordnung muss ich dann schon noch mal
sagen sie hätten diesem Land so viel
ersparen können wenn sie uns nicht
energiewirtschaftspolitisch 16 Jahre
abhängig gemacht hätten vom putin-gas
entgegen sämtlicher Warnung der
Friedensforschung von Energieexperten
und der baltischen Staaten das war eben
keine Krisenvorsorge sondern ist eine
der schwersten Hypotheken der
merkeljahre und das trifft eben heute
alle Sektoren die privaten Haushalte die
Wirtschaft und eben auch die
Wissenschaft und ich sage sehr klar für
diese Koalition wir kümmern uns
unser Wissenschaftssystem muss
krisenfester und zukunftsfit werden und
da sage ich auch guten Morgen liebe und
John ist ja schön dass sie mal endlich
auch einen Antrag stellen aber wir haben
ein
ministerpräsidentin-konferenz Beschluss
wir haben ein KMK-Beschluss wir haben
Eckpunkte der gaspreiskommission die
alle darauf abzielt das Hochschulen und
außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen als Herzstücke
unseres Wissenschaftssystems erstens bei
Energiekosten entlastet werden zweitens
Bund und Länder dafür Sorge tragen dass
die Stromversorgung sichergestellt ist
und drittens diese Infrastrukturen des
Wissens von Schulen bis
großforschungseinrichtung als kritische
Infrastrukturen gesehen werden und nach
drei online Semester mit
campus-lockdowns werden wir Blackouts
und Versorgungsengpässe abwenden und
dafür sorgen dass an den Hochschulen
Präsenz wieder die Regel ist
ich sage für meine Fraktion sehr klar
Hochschulen und außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen gehören ins
gaspreisdeckelgesetz sie gehören von
Bund und Ländern entlastet damit sie
auch gut durch den Winter manövrieren
können und ich kann mir gar nicht anders
vorstellen das ist der
Bundesfinanzminister genauso sieht was
wir nicht brauchen Liebe Union ist ein
wissenschaftsgipfel den sie in ihrem
Antrag vorschlagen wir haben MPK GWK KMK
wir haben ständig gute Gesprächskontakte
zwischen Regierung
koalitionsfraktion und der
Wissenschaftscommunity und wir haben vor
allem ganz viele bottom-up-initiative
wir haben task forces in den Hochschulen
in den Laboren in den einzelnen
Forschungseinrichtungen die alle dafür
sorgen Energie einzusparen effizienter
zu werden die wollen doch auch in
Zeitalter der Klimagerechtigkeit und das
ist Teil des Schutzschirms den wir
stricken
das Problem ist da aber wir arbeiten
daran ist zu lösen und deshalb brauchen
wir keine schaufensteranträge der Union
wir arbeiten im übrigen weiter
konsequent an der zukunftsgerechteten
Bund Länder wissenschaftsfinanzierung
genau in zwei Wochen wird die gemeinsame
Wissenschaftskonferenz den
Zukunftsvertrag Studium und Lehre
beschließen und auch die Neuausrichtung
der Exzellenzinitiative jahrelang liefen
doch Pakt für Forschung und Innovation
für die außeruniversitären und
Hochschulpakt 1 und 2 für die
Hochschulen aneinander vorbei und hat
sich die Finanzierung entkoppelt das
ändert diese Koalition nicht nur die
außeruniversitären kriegen jährlich drei
Prozent sondern künftig auch die
Hochschulen drei Prozent plus das ist
eine Korrektur eines webfehlers und das
ist eine verlässliche finanzierungs-
und das BMBF und die Ampel bereiten auch
vor die weiteren
koalitionsvertragsprojekte aufzugleichen
tenia
track-länderprogramm diversity
Digitalisierung und moderne Governance
das muss im nächsten Jahr bearbeitet
werden Steigerung der programmpauschale
können Sie gerne mitwirken damit die
forschungsstarken Universitäten da auch
entsprechend profitieren denn unsere
Peilung ist klar das 3,5 Prozent sie für
Forschung und Entwicklung ist wichtig
damit die 20er Jahre zum innovations
Jahrzehnt entwickelt werden können eine
auskömmliche Finanzierung ist
unerlässlich dafür sorgen wir wir
brauchen keine schaufensteranträge der
Union die nicht dazu beitragen dass
unser Wissenschaftssystem Exzellenz
bleibt wie es ist vielen Dank
fordert hier für die Grünen unter
anderem dass die Forschungseinrichtungen
aus vom auch vom gaspreisdeckel gesetzt
profitieren sollten vielfach haben ja
auch Task Forces an Universitäten und
Forschungseinrichtungen jetzt schon
Maßnahmen zum Einsparen von Energie
umgesetzt aus dem
Paralleluniversum in dem es überhaupt
gar kein Problem gibt zurück in die
leider Realität in der wir eben doch ein
Problem haben und diese Probleme wollen
wir lösen und es ist sehr von vielen
meiner Vorredner ein richtigerweise
schon gesagt worden die herausragend die
Bedeutung der Wissenschaft der
wissenschaftsstandorts Deutschland ist
gerade in der Pandemie waren es nämlich
unsere Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die Tag und Nacht daran
gearbeitet haben geforscht haben dass
sie uns wieder ein Stück weit Normalität
auch zurückgeben können und jetzt
jetzt sind wir in der neuen Situation
die ist nicht weniger schwierig als die
alte leider kann uns halt jetzt die
Wissenschaft zumindest kurzfristig nur
bedingt weiterhelfen und trotzdem
forschen sie Tag für Tag an den
drängenden Problemen die wir alle haben
und an diesem oder an oder für die wir
auch einfach Antworten bringen brauchen
leider Fragen die von den anderen Krisen
im Moment überdeckt werden und umso
schlimmer ist es doch dass
offensichtlich die Regierung unsere
Wissenschaft mit unseren ForscherInnen
unseren Forschern zu stiefmüttleren
mütterlich bislang in dieser Krise
behandelt hat die fortschrittsregierung
wie sie sich gerne nennen muss man
leider jetzt an der Stelle so deutlich
sagen hat keinen Blick sie hat
offensichtlich auch kein Herz für
Fortschritt und Zukunft
und vielleicht
fehlt Ihnen auch ein Stück weit an dem
richtigen und detaillierten Blick auf
das was die Forscherinnen und Forscher
gerade so beschäftigt jeden Tag
zumindest habe ich irgendwie in der
letzten Rede das Gefühl gehabt dass da
der Blick fehlt deswegen helfen wir an
der Stelle gerne ein Stück weit auf die
Sprünge haben sie sich haben Sie sich
zum Beispiel schon mal Gedanken darüber
gemacht was für Auswirkungen
Temperaturunterschiede in Laboren auf
bestimmte Experimente haben können
ich kann mich noch gut daran erinnern
wenn Kolleginnen und Kollegen von mir
bestimmte Experimente nur an den Tagen
angesetzt haben wo der Wetterbericht
netrekordtemperaturen nach oben oder
unten angesetzt hat vorher gesagt hat
weil nämlich bestimmte Bakterien und
Enzyme dann keine reproduzierbare
Ergebnisse mehr produzieren
und deswegen ist an den Tagen einfach
das nicht gemacht worden mangels
Klimaanlage weil die Ergebnisse zu sehr
abgeweicht hätten oder lassen Sie uns
einfach mal über die Doktoranden
sprechen die monatelang teilweise
jahrelang an bestimmten Tiermodellen
gearbeitet getüftelt hat um ein
spezielles gehen zu verändern und dann
hat sie endlich die ersten Mäuse
in ihrem in ihrem thierstall in den
Käfigen die entsprechend gezüchtet sind
so dass Sie sich für die Versuche
verwenden kann sie freut sich dass sie
jetzt am Ende nur noch die Screenings
und Tests durchführen muss dass sie die
Arbeit dann abschließen kann und dann
stromausfallen die Mäuse haben überhaupt
keine Chance dass sie in dem Tierstall
in bei sinkenden Temperaturen ohne
Luftfilter überleben können und die
Doktoranden was ist mit der Doktoranden
die steht von dem Scherbenhaufen vor den
Trümmern ihrer jahrelangen Arbeit ohne
eine Chance dass sie die Ergebnisse
irgendwie noch zurückholen kann und ohne
Chance auf die Wissen auf die Ergebnisse
die die Wissenschaft zu dringend braucht
es scheint den Busch zu sein
offensichtlich oder was ist denn zum
Beispiel mit der Ärztin die über Jahre
hinweg Gewebeproben von Patienten mit
seltenen Erkrankungen gesammelt hat dass
sie Stück für Stück die Proben auf neue
Erkenntnisse und untersuchen kann man
kann sich überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen
was für ein Schaden entsteht die
Wissenschaft und nicht nur für die
Wissenschaft viel schlimmer noch für die
betroffenen Patienten wenn Sie die wenn
diese Proben auf einen Schlag vernichtet
werden weil der -80 Grad Gefrierschrank
hat einfach mal zu lange keinen Strom
mehr gehabt hat
Frau Ministerin sie sind
Bundesforschungsministerin sie haben vor
ihrer sie haben es ist aber naja sie
haben vor ihrer Zeit als Ministerin viel
an Universitäten und Forschungszentrum
gearbeitet viele in der Community waren
begeistert dass jetzt sozusagen eine
Insiderin das ist Amt bekleiden wird die
Ernüchterung ist leider groß und das zu
Recht und da hilft es jetzt ehrlich
gesagt auch nicht dass sie heute im
Handelsblatt ankündigen was wir hier
schon lange gefordert haben und was wir
hier in unserem Antrag jetzt auch wieder
fordern es hilft deswegen nicht weil die
weil die Anhörung zu unserem Antrag von
ihnen erst auf den 30 november angesetzt
worden ist das ist zu spät und zwar
deutlich
[Applaus]
deshalb der dringende Appell an sie
erstens berufen sie schnellstmöglich an
den Energiegipfel für die Wissenschaft
ein hören Sie sich die Berichte von dem
Betroffenen an damit sie in klares Bild
von den Herausforderungen kriegen die
die Wissenschaft aktuell hat und
schnüren Sie dann darauf basierend ein
zielgerichtetes entlassungspaket für die
Wissenschaft und eine Notfallfonds für
die besonderen Belange von Wissenschaft
und Forschung statt hier mit langen
Ankündigungen am Ende doch nichts
umzusetzen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen denken Sie auf die denken sie
an die Zukunft denken Sie an den
Fortschritt in Deutschland weil in aller
Regel sind die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler die den Grundstein für
unsere Zukunft den Grundstein für
unseren Fortschritt in Deutschland und
für die ganze Welt legen Deutschland hat
ein hervorragendes System aber das
müssen wir jetzt in dieser durchaus
herausfordernden und schwierigen
Situationen
unterstützen statt dass wir es kaputt
machen weil die zuständige Ministerin
auf dem wissenschaftlichen Auge
offensichtlich blind ist und die
Wissenschaft in der Krise von der
Regierung schlichtweg vergessen worden
ist danke
Katrin Staffler war das ja und sie sagt
für die Union die Zeit dränge und zeigte
sich vor allem auch unzufrieden damit
dass zu diesem Antrag wo es ja um diesen
Notfallfonds Wissenschaftssystem gehen
soll das dazu die Expertenanhörungen im
Ausschuss erst am 30 November seit
zusteht Ria Schröer Schröer Schröder
Verzeihung jetzt für die FDP er zeigt
sich in der Ukraine als Zerstörung von
Leben und Familien von Schulen und
Spielplätzen als Terror gegen die
Zivilgesellschaft der Angriffskrieg
betrifft uns auch in Deutschland seine
Folgen sind für uns Inflation und
Energieknappheit dafür verantwortlich
ist einzig und allein Vladimir Putin die
einzigen die was anderes behaupten das
sind die kremlknechte hier auf der
rechten Seite von der Alternative für
Russland
Privathaushalte Unternehmen das Handwerk
stehen unter hohem Druck genauso wie
Bildungs- und Wissenschaftseinrichtungen
wir handeln deshalb energiepolitische
Weichenstellung die sind jetzt
entscheidend der weitere
Leistungsbetrieb aller drei deutschen
Kernkraftwerke ist vernünftig
verantwortungsvoll und richtig denn das
senkt Energiepreise sorgt für
Netzstabilität und ist ein Gebot
europäischer Stabilität
Solidarität gleichzeitig müssen wir mit
dem massiven Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien langfristig Klimaneutralität
und Unabhängigkeit erreichen und so auch
unseren Wissenschaftsstandort resilient
machen
zum Wissenschaftsbetrieb meine Damen und
Herren gehören auch Studierende
Promovierende sie sind nach zwei
sorgenwintern in denen die Unis
geschlossen waren mürbe und frustriert
von der Ungewissheit auch wenn die
Universitäten mit den steigenden
Energiekosten kämpfen sollten Sie den
Studierenden jetzt Sicherheit geben und
zusagen dass die Präsenzlehre im
Wintersemester stattfindet online wäre
und hybride Angebote dürfen kein
Notnagel sein sondern sie sollten dann
genutzt werden wenn das didaktisch
sinnvoll ist eine Umstellung auf eine
digitale Lehre und Kosten zu sparen das
würde die Krise wieder auf den Schultern
der Studierenden Abladen wir müssen raus
mit den hörsäen und Bibliotheken aus der
lockdown-spirale
[Applaus]
Bund Länder und Hochschulen müssen
gemeinsam dazu beitragen die Hochschulen
sind anders als sie das hier eben
dargestellt haben auch nicht völlig
verloren die haben auch so was wie
Notstromaggregate Notfallpläne lassen
wir die doch nicht ärmer aussehen als
sie sind für die gestiegenen Kosten da
braucht es enge Abstimmung zwischen
Ländern und Hochschulen wo kann selbst
aus Rücklagen noch etwas gestemmt werden
wo es Unterstützung nötig und für die
Sicherheit bei der Energieversorgung da
hat die Ministerin ja bereits erreicht
das Hochschulen als geschützte Kundinnen
gelten also in einer mangelage
priorisiert werden zudem müssen das
haben wir darüber haben wir schon
gesprochen Wissenschaftseinrichtungen
von den Entlastungen durch den
wirtschaftlichen abwehrschirmen
unterstützt werden denn Wirtschaft und
Wissenschaft sind beide Pfeiler für
Wohlstand in unserem Land heute und in
Zukunft
in dieser Zeit meine Damen und Herren
müssen wir Hand in Hand gehen und näher
zusammenrücken in den Hörsälen wie in
der Politik zwischen Bund und Ländern
und auch zwischen Regierungen und
Opposition freue mich deshalb auf die
weiteren Beratungen im Ausschuss vielen
Dank
ja Schröder war das für die FDP-Fraktion
hat sie gesprochen sie ist die
bildungspolitische Sprecherin sehr
Fraktionen weiter in der Aussprache mit
Caroline Wagner für die SPD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit Beginn des
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskriegs
Putins auf die Ukraine ist die
Bundesregierung mit Hochdruck dabei die
Ukraine in ihrem Verteidigungskampf zu
unterstützen den hier angekommenen
geflüchteten Menschen aus der Ukraine
Schutz zu bieten und die negativen
Auswirkungen dieses Krieges hier in
Deutschland abzudämpfen
wenn ich in dem vorliegenden Antrag der
Union also lese Zitat die
Bundesregierung ist jetzt aufgefordert
die Leistungs- und Zukunftsfähigkeit der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu sichern
dann kann ich nur sagen diese
Bundesregierung tut seit dem 24 Februar
nichts anderes als die Leistungs- und
Zukunftsfähigkeit der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland zu sichern würden wir jetzt
damit anfangen wäre es viel zu spät
während ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender Mitte
März einen gaslieferstopp forderte hat
diese Bundesregierung mit Hochdruck am
lng-beschleunigungsgesetz gearbeitet um
neue Wege zur Versorgung mit Gas zu
erschließen hat diese Bundesregierung
mit Hochdruck am osterpaket gearbeitet
um die erneuerbaren Energien zu
beschleunigen und zu entfesseln während
also ihr Friedrich Merz einen
gaslieferstopp forderte der uns heute
der uns jetzt in einen verheerenden
Winter hätte gehen lassen in dieser Zeit
hat diese ampelregierung die Leistungs-
und Zukunftsfähigkeit der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland gesichert
aktuell
aktuell liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
bauen wir an einer Strom und an einer
gaspreisbremse die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger Unternehmen und eben auch
Forschungs- und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen entlassen
wird entlasten wird das hat Olaf Scholz
erst diese Woche bei seiner Rede bei
akatech deutlich gemacht und es ist doch
ganz klar dass diese zentralen
Einrichtungen umfasst sein müssen von
den Maßnahmen dass wir zentrale Bereiche
die Forschung Bildung Kunst und Kultur
nicht außen vor lassen werden nein
gerade deswegen nehmen wir für die
gaspreisbremse richtig viel Geld in die
Hand 200 Milliarden Euro und warum weil
wir weil diese ampelregierung heute und
jetzt die Zukunftsfähigkeit dieses
Landes sichert werteunion weiter fordern
sie in ihrem Antrag
und sie haben es auch vorgetragen die
Bundesregierung müsste die
Bundesnetzagentur anweisen eine
prioritäre Energieversorgung von
wissenschaftlichen Einrichtungen
vorzunehmen ja kann man machen viel
besser finde ich aber dass diese
Bundesregierung in den letzten Monaten
mit Werft dafür gesorgt hat dass unsere
Gasspeicher vollstände jetzt schon bei
95 Prozent liegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen 95 Prozent und dieser Füllstand
der sichert die Forschungseinrichtungen
in diesem Land weit mehr als es
irgendwelche Anweisungen im Falle einer
gasmangelage tun könnten das muss ich
auch einfach mal so platt zurückspielen
werteunion
eine weitere Forderung in ihrem Antrag
bezieht sich auf den Lehrbetrieb an den
Hochschulen in diesem Wintersemester und
ja es ist absolut richtig dass nach
Jahren des distanzunterrichts jetzt
alles dafür getan werden muss damit
dieses Wintersemester wieder in Präsenz
stattfindet denn studierende sollen
gemeinsam im Hörsaal sitzen den in den
Sprechstunden den Professorinnen
Professoren direkt gegenüber sitzen und
auch in der Cafeteria miteinander
diskutieren in der Bibliothek gemeinsam
lernen Veranstaltungen besuchen das
alles gehört zu einem Studium dazu und
das alles ist uns allen auch sehr
wichtig in der Verantwortung dafür
stehen aber auch die Länder das haben
sie in ihrem Antrag richtigerweise
benannt und wieder Kollege Seiter für
Baden-Württemberg so kann ich aus meinem
Bundesland Bayern sagen dass das
csu-geführte Wissenschaftsministerium
bislang keine zusätzlichen Mittel für
die Hochschulen in Aussicht stellt und
das obwohl Bayern zu einem der reichsten
Bundesländer zählt und gerade von solch
finanzstarken Bundesländern wie Bayern
erwarte ich dass sie ihren Teil der
Verantwortung übernehmen und den Unis
bei den gestiegenen Energiekosten unter
die Arme greifen
und ich hoffe auch
ich hoffe auf sehr liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union das auch Sie ein
großes Stück der Verantwortung mittragen
und dazu bereit sind um die Forschungs-
und Wissens Wissenschaftslandschaft mit
der gaspreisbremse zu unterstützen indem
sie morgen dann auch für die Änderungen
des stabilisierungsvorgesetztes Stimmen
ich bin gespannt vielen herzlichen Dank
Carolin Wagner war das für die
SPD-Fraktion ihr folgt jetzt hier Dieter
Janecek für die Grünen Sitzung
Wirtschaftsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ich freue
mich in dieser Debatte teilhaben zu
dürfen als einer derjenigen die auch den
Koalitionsvertrag zum Kapitel Innovation
Forschung und Lehre mitgestalten durfte
ich finde da haben wir als
fortschrittskoalition wirklich was
brauchbares vorgelegt und deswegen ist
das Signal völlig klar natürlich
schützen wir die Wissenschaft auch in
dieser Energiekrise
die gute Nachricht in Richtung der Union
wir haben Vorsorge getroffen in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten mit den
Maßnahmen rund um das Bundesministerium
für Wirtschaft und Energie dass wir
allerbeste Chancen haben gut durch den
Winter zu kommen was die
Versorgungssicherheit angeht natürlich
das muss man ehrlicherweise sagen sind
nicht alle Eventualitäten ausgeschlossen
Angriffe auf kritisch Infrastrukturen
wie wir sie gesehen haben Nord Stream 1
und 2 jetzt das sind Dinge die wir im
Augenblick haben müssen die wir schützen
müssen aber Forschung Wissenschaft ist
das was wir brauchen in dieser Krise
denn nur mit den Maßnahmen die dort
entwickelt werden das haben sie auch
gesagt ja jetzt haben wir kommen wir
auch aus der Krise raus deswegen ist das
essentiell für unser Land
was wird passieren wir sind bei der
gaspreisbremse sie hat uns angesprochen
und bei der strompreisbremse mit
Hochdruck unterwegs das jetzt zu
gestalten und natürlich ist die
Erwartung dass das auch vollumfänglich
den Wissenschaftsbereich abdecken wird
das heißt die Signale kommen zeitnah
dass man verlässlich auf der preisseite
planen kann und dass man auch
verlässlich versorgungssicher planen
kann dass jetzt aber auch eines voraus
dass Energie eingespart wird und da gibt
es ja im Hochschulbereich schon tolle
Beispiele wie die Leuphana Universität
Lüneburg die zum Beispiel seit 2014
bereits klimaneutral ist die haben schon
40 Prozent Energie eingespart und
produzieren ihre 60% restlichen durch
erneuerbare Energien selbst das wird
nicht allen Hochschulen allen
Universitäten allen
Forschungseinrichtungen vor allem den
energieintensiven kurzfristig in der
Krise helfen aber es ist auch ein Signal
hier an die Koalition und uns selber an
Sie dass wir darum kämpfen müssen dass
die Klimaneutralität in den Hochschulen
jetzt auch erste Priorität kriegt
die Länder ich habe dem ihr den Teilchen
Beschleuniger auch angeschaut lieber
Thomas jazzombeck den kriegen wir jetzt
noch nicht so schnell mit ein paar
Photovoltaik Modulen nach vorne das ist
mir schon klar aber es geht natürlich
darum dass wir jetzt anpacken und die
Voraussetzungen schaffen die er aus der
Forschung kommen um eben resilient zu
werden unabhängig zu werden auf Basis
erneuerbare Energien und
Energieeffizienz und da ist ja die
Erwartung auch dass wir das gemeinsam
mit der Hochschule der
Forschungslandschaft machen das Thema
Einsparung ist trotzdem jetzt relevant
denn nur wenn wir Energie einsparen
werden auch die Preise weiter sinken sie
sinken ja Gott sei Dank übrigens sehr
stark an den spotmarktpreisen momentan
noch sind sie nicht an den Future
Preisen nachvollzogen aber der Trend
stimmt und in Richtung der Länder sei
gesagt das gilt auch an mein Land Bayern
natürlich ist Hochschule auch zentrale
länderverantwortung das heißt
härtefallfonds lieber Markus Söder ist
auch ihre Aufgabe und ist nicht nur
unsere Aufgabe also handeln Sie bitte in
den Ländern das Sicherheit in den Markt
kommt es kann nicht sein dass alle
Verantwortung immer auf den Bund
geschoben wird wir sind ja kr
zusammenarbeiten weil wir warten aber
auch von den Ländern dass ihre Arbeit
erfüllen in diesem Sinne bedanke ich
mich und wünsche eine gute Debatte
ist die nächste Rednerin für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Unionsfraktion
grundsätzlich haben Sie mit Ihrem Antrag
recht ja Deutschland hat eines der
leistungsstärksten wissenschaftssysteme
der Welt ja die hohen Energiepreise
stellen viele Wissenschaftseinrichtungen
und vor große Herausforderungen und ja
steigende Betriebskosten dürfen nicht
zum Stillstand von Forschungen
Innovation führen daran dass ich Ihnen
in all diesen Punkten so bereitwillig
zustimmen merken Sie vielleicht dass sie
uns mit diesem Antrag wirklich überhaupt
nichts Neues offenbaren sondern nur
Sachen die wirklich allen in der
jetzigen Situation bekannt sind und in
der Zeit die sie gebraucht haben um
offentliche offensichtliche Forderungen
zu stellen hat die Ampel nicht nur ein
sondern bereits drei entlastungspakete
auf dem Weg gebracht einen Abwehrschirm
inklusive gaspreisbremse aufgespannt und
denkt schon darüber nach was wir noch
tun können
und Sie liebe Union
sie stellen vielleicht Anträge in denen
sie die überwiegend richtigen Schlüsse
ziehen und nachvollziehbare Forderungen
stellen wenn es aber mal wirklich darauf
ankommt Entlastung auf den Weg zu
bringen dann kneifen sie dann stimmen
sie dagegen wie beim Heizkostenzuschuss
beim 9 euro-ticket bei der
energiepreispauschale beim Kinderbonus
und den beiden bafög-reform und
anscheinend auch beim 200 Milliarden
Euro Abwehrschirm über den wir morgen
abstimmen sie fühlen sich nicht in der
Lage zuzustimmen weil noch zu viele
Fragen offen sein gleichzeit werfen Sie
uns vor wir würden zu lange brauchen wir
würden Entscheidungen und Umsetzungen
vertrödeln und verzögern und
ganz und Entscheidungsfindungsprozessen
zu genau hinschaue wird mir schwindelig
in den vergangenen Monaten haben sie so
viele Pirouetten gedreht dass wir nicht
nur im Parlament sondern auch die
BürgerInnen nicht mehr wissen wofür sie
eigentlich stehen
nun gut zur Wissenschaft wir wissen die
nächsten Monate werden nicht leicht auch
Hochschulen und Forschungseinrichtungen
sind von den steigenden Energie und
Betriebskosten betroffen darauf bereiten
wir uns vor und deshalb stehen wir
darüber schon länger im intensiven
Austausch mit den Hochschulen und
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen es wurden
bereits Energiekonzepte ausgearbeitet
und Notfallpläne erstellt viele
universitäre und außeruniversitäre
Einrichtungen haben einen Plan für den
Winter und der Rest folgt in den
kommenden Wochen unsere partner:innen in
Wissenschaft und Forschung planen aber
nicht nur voraus sie helfen auch schon
jetzt ganz konkret mit sie sparen
Energie wo es nur geht ohne Lehre und
Forschung in Gefahr zu bringen und nicht
nur dafür sind wir dankbar viele
Menschen vergessen schnell welche
Bedeutung Wissenschaft und Forschung für
unsere Gesellschaft haben unsere
wissenschaftler:innen forschen täglich
an Lösungen für die Herausforderung der
gegebenenart und der Zukunft
annovationen für erneuerbare Energien an
konflik und Konflikt und
Krisenprävention und an Fragen eines
nachhaltigen Strukturwandels und für
diese wichtige Arbeit müssen und wollen
wir Ihnen Sicherheit geben diese
Wertschätzung wir Wissenschaft und
Forschung reicht bis ins
Bundeskanzleramt es ist kein Zufall das
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz gerade jetzt
in dieser Zeit einen Zukunftsrat
eingesetzt hat in der VertreterInnen aus
Wissenschaft Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
gemeinsam über die Herausforderungen für
unser Land beraten und es war auch
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz meine
Kolleginnen haben es bereits gesagt der
erst vor ein paar Tagen
zugesichert hat dass auch wir
wissenschafts- und
Forschungseinrichtungen die
gaspreisbremse gelten wird liebe
Kolleginnen die Menschen in unserem Land
machen sich zu recht große Sorgen nicht
nur in der Wissenschaft sondern überall
sie sorgen sich wie Sie Ihre Rechnungen
zahlen sollen ob Strom und Gas für den
Winter reichen ob die Preise im
Supermarkt weiter steigen umso wichtiger
ist es jetzt dass wir Sicherheit geben
und dass wir wie mein Kollege Holger
Mann ist gerade gesagt hat ohne Panik
agieren und nicht wie einige in diesem
Haus im Sinne Putins noch mehr Angst und
Verunsicherung verbreiten und dafür
müssen alle demokratischen Fraktionen
des Hauses zusammenstehen wir müssen
Vertrauen in die Politik fördern anstatt
dieses selbst zu erschüttern der Winter
wird auch schon so schwer und hart genug
für uns alle vielen Dank
die w-unri war das für die SPD-Fraktion
sitzt im Ausschuss für Bildung und
Forschung hier zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt wie sieht die
gaspreisbremse auch für Wissenschaft und
Forschung gesichert weil auch Kanzler
Olaf Scholz ist so schon angekündigt hat
der Antrag der Unionsfraktion der hier
dieser Debatte zugrunde lag der geht
jetzt in die Ausschüsse und wird dort
dann weiter beraten